[Musique]
il donne faire en sorte que les impôts
des contribuables américains
donc les achats publics permettent
d'acheter et de favoriser dès l'achat de
produits américains c'est à dire qu'en
fait s'ils sont moins chers que 20% par
exemple qu'un produit chinoises sont pas
plus chers que 20 % de plus qu'un
produit chinois ils vont être favorisée
donc c'est totalement normal que quand
les gens payent des impôts ça favorise
plutôt des achats de produits nationaux
c'est ce que font les chinois d'ailleurs
les brésiliens et tous les japonais tous
les pays du monde il faut bien préciser
comme hayden ne fait qu'approfondir
cette loi que trump avait déjà
approfondir un petit peu durci qui
s'appelle le buy american act quand
l'administration américaine est dicté
des sanctions donc des restrictions mais
j'insiste entre et le lien entre deux
entre les deux mots lorsque
l'administration américaine et édicte
des sanctions commerciales contre l'iran
vous croyez 2 qu'elle ne le fait pas
pour favoriser la prospérité de
l'économie iranienne
donc la seule le seul effet du
protectionnisme des restrictions
commerciales
c'est de priver les consommateurs de
l'abondance de la diversité des
marchandises au motif que certaines
marchandises seraient en effet
étrangères même si encore une fois la
question de la nationalité des produits
dans un monde où des chaînes de valeur
sont très imbriqué est quand même assez
arbitraire
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la france est soumise à une
législation européenne qui ne lui permet
pas de faire n'importe quoi en matière
de sélection des prestataires
si elle prenait un décret similaire à
mon avis il y aurait quelques problèmes
de compatibilité le droit européen et
sur le plan politique il risque d'y
avoir en effet des mesures de rétorsion
puisque nos entreprises étant tout aussi
dépendante de marchés étrangers
extérieur le risque étant effectivement
de susciter des réactions similaires
auprès des autres pays et donc de
conduire nos entreprises à perdre des
parts de marché
mais la réaction est le véritable
dommage il serait infligé avant tout aux
contribuables et aux usagers de service
public que nous sommes tous puisque je
le répète en tant qu'usagers nous avons
intérêt à être servis par des
entreprises qui font le boulot
correctement et que ces entreprises soit
étrangères ou françaises finalement
importe peu et d'ailleurs le
consommateur lambda
quand il fait ses courses dans un
supermarché généralement il se préoccupe
pas beaucoup de la nationalité des
entreprises
la france est effectivement le dindon de
la farce la mondialisation avec l'union
européenne puisque nous faisons partie
des rares pays du monde à ce que les
actifs qui font que les achats pour les
marchés publics ne favorise pas les
entreprises françaises et même pas les
entreprises de l'union européenne et ça
crée des destructions d'emploi par
exemple pour ta mousson ont récemment
n'a pas été retenu ce qui est une
entreprise française qui est pourtant
une pipe en difficulté réside y avoir
des licenciements ça a été une
entreprise turque a été retenue pour le
marché du canal de provence et les chefs
d'entreprises se sont insurgés à juste
titre là dessus les achats de fusil
français aussi récemment par l'armée où
était faible à une entreprise allemande
alors qu'on était tout à fait capable de
les fabriquer en france voilà
et donc ça c'est l'union européenne qui
nous l'imposent grande partie par ces
directives par la directive de 2004 et
c'est un vrai problème pour l'économie
française avec notre économie est dans
un cercle vicieux
au lieu de détente d'un cercle vertueux
comme les économies qu'ils se protègent
la chine les etats-unis et ses rangs
qu'est ce que le protectionnisme sinon
l'aigreur devant le constat que les
consommateurs se plaisent généralement à
faire leurs courses
indépendamment de la nationalité de
l'entreprise auprès de laquelle elle
achète
ils achètent des produits donc ça aurait
tout paca de tout un tas de conséquences
économiques négatives alors
politiquement oui c'est vrai que c'est
rentable de faire du protectionnisme en
france parce que ça permet de plates et
les instincts cousineau fob de la
population on l'a vu avec carrefour et
couche-tard
mais sur le plan économique ça n'apporte
absolument rien n'y a aucune aigreur je
crois que vous savez les consommateurs
français les citoyens français sont très
heureux par exemple d'acheter des
produits qu'ils soient alimentaires ou
d'autres choses qu'ils soient français
pour soutenir les emplois locaux plutôt
que de créer du chômage en achetant des
produits chinois ce n'est pas de la
xénophobie c'est juste du patriotisme et
ça n'a rien à voir
plus un marché est grand plus le nombre
de participants au marché est élevé plus
il ya des possibilités de spécialisation
plus la division du travail et et de
meilleure qualité et plus nous sommes
tous productif et c'est ainsi que depuis
des décennies l'humanité parvient à
faire reculer la misère dans des
proportions spectaculaires grâce à
l'ouverture du commerce alors bien sûr
que la france n'est pas dans une
situation tout à fait réjouissante mais
enfin nous serions je crois malavisé
d'imputer nos problèmes à la
mondialisation
à mon avis le problème sont d'avantagé à
des facteurs internes des facteurs que
nous ressassons nous libéraux depuis des
décennies un marché du travail trop
rigide et fiscalité spoliatrice qui
décourage les entreprises mais c'est
vrai qu'il est toujours plus facile
entre guillemets de taper sur le
si je peux me permettre je me permettent
pas ce que vous faites des longues
tirades vos préconisations libéral de
mondialisation de libre échange on les
applique depuis 40 ans la croissance
était beaucoup plus élevé dans les pays
occidentaux ya 40 ans l'état 4%
elle est descendue à 3 % 2% et 1% les
français devront se marre de vous
entendre ça c est faire appliquer ces
mesures qui sont très violentes
socialement et qui ne produisent aucune
richesse puisque la preuve
et de la même manière que plus on
applique ses recettes
et plus on se retrouve dès
industrialisés et appauvrit donc la
preuve et dans les réalisations de la
mondialisation vous avez 40 ans on
appliquer les politiques ultra libérales
et libre échangiste et depuis 40 ans
c'est une catastrophe